[inaudible]
joining me today is the author of the
New York Times best seller rise of the
robots technology and the threat
of a jobless future. Martin Ford.
Welcome to the Rubin report. Thanks for
having me. I'm glad to have you here sir.
Because dystopian futures, robots, skynet,
all of it very much in my wheelhouse.
And I want you to explain it all to me.
Are you ready? Yes, definitely.
All right, let's do it. So, uh,
first off before we dive directly
into robots and AI and all that, uh,
just tell me a little bit
about your background.
What brought you to writing a book?
Like?
Okay,
so I studied computer engineering in
college and then I worked as an engineer,
design engineer for several years. Um,
then I went back and studied business.
Eventually I ended up starting and
running a small software company up in
Silicon Valley.
And I ran that for many years.
But even in the course of running that,
I saw the impact that all
this technology was having on,
on jobs at my business
and businesses like it.
And that really got me
thinking about this issue.
And so about 10 years ago in 20, um, 2009,
I wrote, uh, my first book
called delights in the tunnel,
which really argued that artificial
intelligence was going to be the next big
thing in computing and that it was going
to have a dramatic impact in particular
on the job market.
And that book did well enough that it
led to an opportunity to write this book
in 2015 which really got, you
know, quite a bit of attention.
And since then I've kind of shifted my
career to really be a futurist focused on
what AI and robotics means for society
and for the economy and especially for
the job market. So I think they're going
to be some huge challenges there for us.
Right. So we're going to
unpack all of that stuff.
But when you were writing about this
in 2009 where people say are now,
this is just pure science.
Yeah, I mean, I, I, this was initiative
is very much off the radar back then. Um,
it came with a fair amount
of stigma and stigma.
And the reason is that this concern or
fear that machines might take a lot of
jobs and there might be unemployment,
it's, it's an old issue,
has come up many times in the past
going all the way back to the Luddites,
right in England 200 years ago.
And so there's actually
this term neo luddite for,
for a person that that is once
again worrying about this issue.
And so it was quite stigmatized. Um,
so in 2009 when I wrote the book,
um, you know, I was one of
the, the earliest people
to get out there with this.
But since then things have definitely
changed and I see a lot of people much
more concerned about this even
professional economists and so forth.
So there definitely has been a shift in
mentality over this last 10 years when
we've seen things like,
like the advent of,
of self driving cars that
look like they're going to
be arriving soon. So forth.
What were,
what markers where you seeing back in
2009 or a little bit before that even that
were sort of pushing you in.
But the most important thing is
what you might call Moore's law.
The fact that that the power of computers
is accelerating doubling every two
years.
And it was obvious that computers were
going to get dramatically more powerful
and there had to be an
application for that.
It has to be something
you can do with that.
And it became obvious to me
that artificial intelligence
was going to be the
thing.
And,
and AI means essentially solving the same
kinds of problems that the human brain
can solve,
right?
And it means machines that in a limited
sense are taking on cognitive capability
to beginning to think.
And that means that technology is going
to begin to compete with and substitute
for human being a human beings in,
in a unique way.
Something that we've never seen before.
And is that scales across the whole
economy has all kinds of jobs,
skilled jobs and unskilled
jobs. I think that, um,
it becomes pretty clear that the,
you know,
it's going to have dramatic implications.
So when people think about robots,
I think like there's a,
there's a few different
ways you can think about it,
that you can sort of think about AI,
which is sort of the same morphous thing
that people sort of don't contextualize
it to a physical object. Then they think
of robots. They think of like, you know,
c three Po and R Two d two
and everything else. Um,
what
if you were just saying robots,
what exactly are you
right? I, especially in this
book, rise of the robust,
I used a very broad meaning for that.
I stay to mean anything that is,
is automating something and taking over,
you know, things that people can do.
And very often that's just
going to be software. Um,
if you want to be more
precise and technical.
A robot is when you take
artificial intelligence and
you put it into a physical
machine that can physically
manipulate the environment.
But what we're talking about is much
broader than that. Um, so we're gonna,
you know,
we're,
we're already seeing people like lawyers
and doctors being impacted and it's not
physical robots. It's often just
software, artificial intelligence. Um,
and actually the,
you know,
building physical robots
that have dexterity that can
manipulate the environment.
That's actually one of the
hardest aspects of this.
And in some ways that where it may be
where progress is going to be slowest,
where in knowledge type work,
you know,
someone that's sitting in front of
a computer doing some routine tasks,
cranking out the same
report again and again,
that may actually be much easier to
automate them then something physical.
So That's interesting.
So the,
the idea part of it is easier to
replicate than the physical part,
even though you'd think that just
building a robot that can move the way you
want it to move or something that seems
technically easier than figuring out how
to think like humans.
It seems like that from our perspective
very often the reason is that to do
these knowledge based jobs requires a
lot of education and training, right?
Um, but actually once you
implement the technology,
it actually can often be the reverse.
The hardest thing to do is to build
a physical robot that has dexterity,
that has visual perception,
that can can move around the way a person
does it take to build, as you said,
to kind of robot like c three Po from
Star Trek. That's totally science fiction.
We don't have anything remotely like that.
It seems like we're caught every now
and again you'll see a video on youtube
where they're getting a little closer.
You know, they've got a robot, you know,
jumping over something and
ducking under something. Exactly.
You see those robots in particular from
a company called Boston dynamics is
doing very impressive things,
but those videos are highly choreographed.
The robots are controlled by
someone that's outside the picture.
This is not a thinking autonomous robot
running around doing stuff by itself.
Okay.
Terminator land just yet.
Not, not anytime soon at all. That's
far in the future, but that, you know,
we shouldn't allow,
we shouldn't be distracted from the fact
that the are things happening now that
are going to have a
really dramatic impact,
but it's not the science fiction stuff
that you see in the I robot movie and,
and stuff like.
Right. So how much of the conversation
is about all of this is about what you
referenced a moment ago about just the
speed of technology and that every two
years the power doubles and all that,
that we're all walking around
with iPhones or cell, you know,
we have super computers in our pocket
and the way we can transmit information
across the globe like that. And just how
much of this is just related to speed
more than,
I know that's a very big part of it.
It is not just the speed of computers
that have gotten faster and smaller of
course, and now during our iPhones, but,
um, it's the speed of communications,
bandwidth,
it's memory capacity.
So we've seen this very
broad based acceleration in
technology and that's a huge
part of it.
Um,
the other things is that there have
been some breakthroughs in artificial
intelligence,
especially in the hottest area of Ai,
which is called deep learning
or deep neural networks.
We've seen dramatic progress there
and that's the thing that's really
revolutionizing the field.
And,
and the other thing that's happened is
that we are now throughout our whole
economy and society collecting
huge amounts of data, right?
There's all this data out
there that wasn't there before.
And this data is basically the resource
that is used to train these smart
algorithms. And that's what artificial
intelligence looks like right now.
It's primarily machine learning.
Um,
and then he's just going to
be incredibly disruptive.
Yeah.
So as part of the potential problem here
that we're building things that will be
more powerful than us and we
don't really understand that.
So it's like we're putting so much
information in our brains all the time.
Maybe our actual physical
brains can't take all this in.
Like we don't have enough ram and our
physical brains for all of the information
that we're constantly slamming ourselves.
Well, it is definitely true that these
smart algorithms, I mean they can look at,
you know, huge amounts of data, millions
and millions and millions of data points,
right?
Which no human being could do.
So we already have our rhythms that in
a very narrow sense in terms of doing
very specific things are superhuman,
right? They can vastly outperform,
um, want any person does. Um,
and they do things that we
don't really understand it.
Good example of that would be Wall Street,
right?
Where you've got these trading algorithms
that can actually look at machine
readable news.
I mean,
companies like Bloomberg actually make
a news products that are designed for
machines,
not for people.
These algorithms can read that news and
then analyze it and then on it within,
you know, tiny fractions of a second.
So that would be an example of,
of where technology is already getting
ahead of what we can understand. Uh,
what do we do to rein some of it back
in occasionally? Well, I, you know,
if there are any lower or is it just
once we start the process with anything
like this, we just don't know where
it is. It's a difficult question. Um,
you know, they're going to be places
where we're going to need regulation. Um,
you can't just rein it in. I mean
it's progress. It's happening.
It says happening in part because
of a competitive dynamic, right?
Within capitalism between companies,
between Google and Facebook and Goldman
Sachs all competing to build, um,
the latest technology.
There is also a competition between
United States and China. Um,
all of that is going to push it forward
relentlessly and trying to stop it. Um,
it's probably kind of a fool's errand.
Um, it's probably not possible and,
and probably not,
not really advisable.
What I think we have to do are find
ways to adapt to all of this progress.
And in some places that may
mean certainly regulation. Um,
and in other cases it will mean finding
ways to address issues like unemployment
in inequality that will, um,
result from all of this progress.
So let's just define some basic terms
cause I think we ended up throwing out a
lot of big terms here and
then people are confused.
So just when people are
talking about the algorithm,
can you just explain in simple terms
what is the algorithm? Well and that was,
we're doing this on youtube right now,
right?
We're always obsessed with
the algorithm and algorithm.
It's just essentially a computer program.
It's something that goes step
by step and does something. Um,
what we've seen recently though is the
emergence of a new kind of algorithm
called machine learning algorithms.
And this is what's really disruptive
and the difference between a machine
learning algorithm and a traditional
computer programming a algorithm is that,
you know,
historically some programmer has,
has sat down and told the computer to
do what to do step by step with machine
learning.
Instead you've got a smart algorithm
that looks at lots and lots of data and
then figures out for itself what to do.
So in essence, it's kind of programming,
it's programming itself,
right? Yeah. Um, so,
so is there a way to control it then?
Well you his interest actually
uncontrollable because once,
once it's learned enough it
just doesn't need the player.
It's not so much that it's
uncontrollable, but that, you know,
we don't really want to control it.
The whole point is to to unleash
it and let it learn and do things.
That doesn't mean that it's in any sense
out of control or it's a danger to us
or anything like,
well the reason I was asking was sort of
through through Youtube Algorithm Lens.
Like one of the things we're finding out
is they just want to keep you clicking
all the time. You know where
we put out a long form show,
people are going to watch a
full hour of our discussion.
That's not really what
the algorithm wants.
It wants you from the way we
understand it from some insiders,
they want you to constantly be clicking
on videos and basically fall into this
click hole to just keep the machine
going.
More and more and more.
Now I understand why they want that sort
of attention going in different places
and all that. Um, but for what I do,
I don't love the algorithm at the moment,
right? Right. So that depends on
how they optimize the algorithm.
But what's happening now is that you've
got millions and millions of people
watching youtube videos.
And if they watch an entire video,
then that will create a data
point that says, you know,
they were really interested in this. If
they, if they start watching and you know,
for a brief time and then they click away,
then it'll show that they're
less interested and then
an algorithm comes around
and looks at millions of those data
points and can make recommendations for
other videos.
And as you said,
I think what we've seen is that the video
shown to people become more extreme,
right?
So if you're interested in something and
then you'll get a more extreme version
of that. And that's how to get people
to Click. And a lot of people have been,
you know,
raising the alarm over that because that
is kind of radicalizing people, right?
So what do you do about that?
If you're,
if you're a programmer and you're at
youtube and you don't want people to be
radicalized or just,
you don't,
even if you just don't want people to
have to just be endlessly clicking,
like there's this game to keep people
addicted to all of these things.
And it's like, I understand that we
could put out a zillion clips so I could,
you know,
I could chop everything into two minute
things and we could put them out and it
would probably help us in terms of
views and all of those things. Um,
but I just don't want
to play that game too.
Right,
right.
Technically I don't think
that's a difficult problem
that that depends on what
the designer wants to do that.
But the whole problem is that
the algorithms are designed
to make the most money
for Google. Right? Right. And that's
what's driving that. So it's not a,
I don't think it's a computer
design problem. It's,
it's a capitalism problem,
a profitability problem.
It's the fact that that Google is a
publicly traded companies. It, you know,
it's, investors want it to
make as much money as possible.
And that's what drives it to design
algorithms that maximize profitability.
So keep your clicker.
That may be the kind of place where maybe
some regulation has to come in and say,
you know, well, you're going to have to
put some constraints on this. Um, if,
if Google doesn't make the
decision to do that itself.
Yes. I mean this is where
I'm not a regulation guy,
but it's like they're pushing
me to my limits. I mean,
this is what I keep saying about all the
tech companies right now when it comes
to censorship and everything else,
it's like they're not giving
us much of a choice here.
Right? I mean, it's a challenging problem
for sure too, to figure out, you know,
for AI to figure out what's in the
video and in terms of is there something
there, then it should be censored or
not. That's the decision they're making.
And that's, that's quite
different from just optimizing,
getting people to watch videos,
because in order to do that, you know,
you don't care what's in the video.
That's the whole problem. Right? Right.
It's just tracking statistics.
But if you actually want to
analyze what's in the video,
is there something in there it dangerous
or you inciting people to violence or
something like that for artificial
intelligence to figure that out,
it's still much, much harder. And that's
why we're running into this problem.
I think.
How is deep learning different than
artificial intelligence? That's, yeah,
that's just the next level of order.
Official intelligence facing is a kind of,
of artificial intelligence is right now
the hottest area of AI and deep learning
or deep neural networks basically means
a system that is loosely designed on the
way a brain would work.
It has artificial neurons that are
roughly similar to to the neurons in your
brain. And that's the way it works. Um,
and this is an idea that's been around,
you know, for, since
the 1950s at least. Um,
but just within the last six years or so,
we've seen just an explosion
in this technology. Um,
and we've now got systems that
can translate languages, um,
from Chinese to English that can do
better than people at recognizing visual
images.
We've got radiology systems that can
look at medical images and find cancer
there and in some cases can do
that better than human doctors.
So this is absolutely, absolutely
the hardest area of Ai. It's, um,
also what's enabling self
driving cars, for example. Um,
so is this the great catch 22 of,
of all of robotics is that it's doing
these incredible things and then as you
talk about in the book, it's going
to put a lot of people out of work.
Well, I think that's one of the real
problems with it. I mean, and you know,
we're ultimately going to have to make
a choice as to whether we want to allow
that progress to continue and get the
enormous benefits of that progress.
But if that's going to come at a cost of,
of making some set of our
population unemployable or,
or maybe deskilling jobs to the point
where people just don't have adequate
incomes, even if they don't,
even if they do have a job, um,
then we've got to find a way to adapt to
that. Right? And that's why, for example,
I've talked a lot about a universal
basic income as one possible approach to
that.
Um,
but I'm very much against the idea that
we should stop progress because this is
where we are,
you know,
this is what progress is going to look
like in the future and we don't want to
stop it because progress is the thing
that is made us better off over.
Is there any evidence that
you are ever in history?
You could stop progress actually. And
even if we want it to stop it right now,
let's say you laid out the greatest case
why this thing is going to run out of
control. It's going to put half
of us out of business, you know,
income inequality is going to go
crazy, poverty, et cetera, et cetera.
Is there any case where technology
existed that we somehow put the,
put the brakes on it?
I'd be quite skeptical that we'd
be able to do that. Um, again,
in part because of competition,
not just between companies but between
countries. Maybe we would do it,
but then China didn't put the brakes
on and they would pretty soon be vastly
ahead of us. Right. So
that would be a problem.
Is that the catch 22 then for regulation
because it's like we may try to
regulate some of it,
but if China's not regulating it or,
exactly. Yeah. One of that's one of
the biggest problems is that you would,
you would put your country
at a disadvantage unless
you could do it on a global
basis.
And of course,
doing anything on a global basis is
incredibly hard as you see with climate
change, for example. Um, so again,
my perspective is that rather
than trying to slow it down,
what we should do is find a way to
adapt to a ledge, just let it run,
but understand what the implications
are going to be and figure out a way to
adapt to that. And that's where the
idea of a basic income comes in.
So I want to talk a little bit more
about ubi, but before we do that,
can you talk a little bit just about
how this has affected certain industries
and how some industries haven't quite
been affected yet? Right. So in general,
the point that I'd make is that it's
going to affect everything. I mean,
artificial intelligence is
going to be like a utility.
It's going to be like electricity,
right?
And no one says what industries are most
impacted by electricity, right? I mean,
you know, everything relies
on electricity, right?
And the same will be true of artificial
intelligence and machine learning. So, um,
in the long run, it's everywhere. Um,
in the near term, clearly, you know,
manufacturing has already been
impacted by automation. Generally.
We've seen a dramatic decrease in advanced
countries and the number of people
employed in manufacturing, and
that's going to continue, uh,
the robots and the automation used in
factories are going to get a lot more
effective, more dexterous. There'll
be able to do the jobs that,
that right now only people can do.
Um, but it's gonna scale to many,
many other areas in finance. Um,
it's going to have a dramatic impact.
A lot of white collar jobs there where
people are sitting in front of a computer
cracking out reports or
something. Right? Um,
recently I saw something that
the CEO of a Deutscha Bank,
one of the big bank said he thought he
could get rid of half of his employees in
the relatively near future
using using this technology. Um,
healthcare is,
and it's an area where it's going to
be slower because it's really hard.
You've got doctors and nurses that need
to engage with patients on a one on one
basis, right? And provide a lot
of individual human like service.
Um,
and it's been,
and that's one of the reasons that
healthcare costs are so high in the United
States right now because we have not
seen the kind of productivity increases
there that we've seen in
say manufacturing. So what,
what could we do to see that we're,
we're,
we're beginning to see evidence of that.
As I mentioned,
you've got systems now that
can read medical images.
So you're going to begin to see,
uh,
the introduction of artificial
intelligence in medicine.
I don't think that it will for the
most part, at least in the near term,
it's not going to
completely replace doctors,
but it will become kind
of a second opinion. Um,
it will run alongside a doctor, you know,
we'll always be there. We will make, um,
every doctor be able to perform at the
level of the best doctor, right? Because,
because there'll be this
incredible intelligence there.
So that will be an enormous benefit.
Um,
there are lower and then eventually if
you just extrapolate that down the road,
he could replace the
doctor too. Right? I mean,
I like in the movie alien in a
million other things. Exactly. I'm,
although I would say in general,
doctors are relatively safe because
they are highly regulated, right?
There are all kinds of rules about
medicine and you need to have a doctor or,
or a pharmacist there and, and those,
so those roles are relatively protected,
protected where if you're a white collar
job and some corporations sitting in a
cubicle somewhere, you don't
have any protections at
all. So for that reason, um,
I would worry a bit less about doctors
a disappearing in the near term.
But you know,
in healthcare there definitely are
going to be lots of applications.
You already see robots in
hospitals delivering things. Um,
you see robots beginning to be used in
elder care looking after older people,
which is certainly one of the biggest
opportunities because we have this aging
population. Um, pharmacy
robots are, are huge things.
They're already robots that do,
you know,
thousands and thousands of
per Chris Prescriptions in,
in hospitals and so forth,
very efficiently. So this is coming. Um,
it will take a little bit longer in
healthcare than in some other areas. Um,
but eventually it's going
to be everywhere. Um, in
retail, you know, they're,
they're, uh, Walmart is
beginning to introduce, uh,
robots and of course, retail in general
is migrating more and more toward Amazon.
Um, which in theory means
that jobs, you know,
they might move from a retail
store to an Amazon warehouse,
but once the jobs go to
that Amazon warehouse,
now they're in a very controlled
environment and there are already lots of
robots there.
And those robots are going to get
dramatically better in the next five or 10
years, you know? So in effect,
you could have a giant Amazon warehouse
that we've all driven by one of these,
these huge monstrosities and it
could basically be run by all robots.
And you're getting very close to that.
And definitely a lot fewer people. I mean,
right now inside those robots,
inside those warehouses,
you have huge numbers of robots and the
robots will do something like bring a
whole shelf of inventory to a worker,
but then the workers got to reach in
there and grab the item off the shelf and
put it in the box because the
robot right now can't do that.
It doesn't have the visual perception
and the dexterity to do that.
But that will change over
the next five to 10 years.
And so those environments are going
to become a lot less labor intensive.
That's not to say they'll
be fully automated,
but there are going to
be fewer jobs there.
And that's something to worry about
because this is one of the brightest areas
right now for job creation.
Right?
So we're gonna so we're going to watch
a certain sector or many sectors of jobs
just disappear altogether.
And yet at the same time,
I guess the counter argument
or the people that would say,
we shouldn't be so alarmed
about this, we'd say, well,
all the costs of everything will go down
because the robots will be able to do
things at a much more
efficient, cheaper level. Right.
So people won't need as much disposable
income, that sort of thing. That's right.
I mean that's absolutely true there.
I am very skeptical that that's kind
of solves the problem though. Me,
you can think about it. If you don't have
a job at all, then your income is zero.
It doesn't matter how matter,
how cheap stuff is.
The other thing is that the
really big ticket items,
the things that really are putting people
under water, our housing, education,
health care, and these are
exactly the areas where, um,
technology is at least in the short
and medium term going to have the least
impact, right? I mean
housing in particular,
some day we might have big
three d printers that make
it really cheap to produce
housing, but, but there's still
a problem with land right in the,
if you're in Los Angeles or, or up in
San Francisco, then there's no land left,
right? It's already know, you
know, it's already very scarce and,
and that's what drives
property values so high.
So you can't solve that problem and
necessarily just with technology.
So as incomes fall, um, you know,
many people are not going to have the
income to really cover the basics and that
that's going to be a big problem.
Okay. So that's the right transition
then to universal basic income. So my,
my default position on UBI,
and I've heard arguments on both sides
and I think I told you I have Andrew Yang
coming in soon and we'll
discuss it further.
My default position is that if you
give people just enough to survive,
that you're sort of stealing just like
the most basic human right of just like
go get something for yourself and that
it's going to create this class of people
sort of not by their own fault that we'll
just have the bare minimum to get by
and then there'll be able to stay at
home and play video games and watch porn
and basically do nothing
all day long and will,
and that's actually taking something
from them rather than giving something to
them. That's sort of my sort of like
high level philosophic position on it.
Right. I, I,
the argument I would make is that once
the society reaches a certain level of
prosperity as we have,
um,
if you want to continue to have capitalism
and a market is very important to
have the kind of incentive that,
that you're alluding to there.
But I would argue that maybe the incentive
doesn't have to be so daunting that
if you don't work, you're living on the
street or eating out of garbage cans,
right.
That maybe it's enough to say that you
can basically survive if you're not
motivated, but you're not
going to have a terrific life.
You're not going to have a great life.
And I think that that a number of studies
have been done with basic income that
showed that when you
give people this money,
they don't in fact just drop out
and stay home and do nothing.
They are actually motivated
to do something more. Um,
they invest in their family and education.
They work if they can,
they may be start a small business.
So actually if you give people
that basic safety net, um,
you can create an environment where
people are actually more willing to take
risks. So for example, they
might start a new business.
They might be willing to leave a safe
job where they're not learning anything.
They're not growing and work for a
startup company, do something more risky.
Right.
Um, but as the inherent problem that
then if they start getting some success,
then they lose the ubi.
No, no, no. See that's, that's the
whole solution to a basic income.
And that's what makes it different from
other forms of safety is that it is
unconditional in a sense
that everyone gets it.
Now what that means is that if I get my
basic income and I choose to just play
video games,
then I'll have that basic income.
But if someone else is more ambitious,
they get their basic income and they go
and work, even if it's only part time,
they start a small business,
then they,
they get the basic income and they
also get that additional income.
We don't tax it away,
at least not at the lower level.
So the key point is that the person
that is productive that is willing to do
something to work will always be better
off than the person that does nothing.
Right? And that's really
key to it because, um,
the problem with our existing social
safety net is exactly what you said,
that if you do something, find a
job, then you lose those benefits.
The cliff has to be really high. They
need to be willing to leave. Yeah.
Right. Right. And that's exactly what
it's called, a poverty trap. Right?
As you get into a situation where you
look at the options around you and,
and anything you do,
does it make you better offer you
gonna makes you work softened.
So you're stuck there.
He can't move.
The worst possible example of that in
United States is the social security
disability program,
right?
Which is intended for people that are
injured on the job and then they can't
work. But actually a lot of people now
are gaming it probably because they're
desperate.
They need an income.
And so they'll go and tell their doctor
they've got pain in their back or
something and they'll get through the
loops and they'll get onto this program,
which gives you an income.
But once you get there,
you can't even be seen to be able bodied.
People are worried even to go and work
in their garden or something because
someone will see them and then they'll
lose their benefits. Right. Um,
so that's a really terrible example of
this kind of income where basic income,
we give it to everyone and it's
unconditional. And then we,
we encourage people to do more. Right.
And that, that, that's really important.
That's one of the strongest
arguments for a basic income scheme.
Yeah. So let's get into some of the
nuts and bolts of it. First off,
do you view it as something that
would have to be done federally?
Because obviously if you live
in Los Angeles or San Francisco,
your cost of living is way higher
than say if you live in Missouri.
So is this a, is this a federal program?
Are we throwing this to the states?
Yeah, I would imagine it needs to
be done on a national level. Um,
and the reason is what you can think
of as kind of like the kind of adverse
selection problem you get
in in insurance, right? If,
if Los Angeles has a basic income,
then people all over the country are
going to move to Los Angeles to get that
right. And they're going to show up here
and, and, and overwhelming the system.
So it needs to be national
rather than, than local. Right.
But what do you do about the
disparity in cost of living
and all these places? Well, you know,
one issue there is that a
basic income is mobile, right?
So maybe you don't have to live
in Los Angeles or San Francisco.
You can take your basic income and
you can move to Detroit, right?
And Dare you might have a pretty
decent life. Um, you, you,
you can have housing.
They're much cheaper. Right?
So the difference between a basic
income and a job is that you can take it
everywhere. So people would
kind of readjust and they might,
some people might choose to leave,
leave high cost areas and,
and live in cheaper places and so forth.
So how do you find all this?
That always is the big one.
Are you scrapping all the social programs
that exist right now or are your tax
and billionaires out the Wazoo?
Well, combination there. Nobody think
definitely you need to raise more revenue.
Um,
I think inevitably one of the things that
we are seeing with the economy largely
as a result of,
of technology is that more and more income
is going to capital unless it's going
to labor.
So businesses and investors and people
like that are getting more income and
average working people are getting less.
So what that means for the future.
I think it's inevitable that we're going
to have to tax capital more and labor
less.
Um,
and that may involve higher business
taxes are taxes on the wealthiest people
that have access a lot. Lots of
capital mean that's as a libertarian,
you might find that objectionable, but
I think it's inevitable. You ultimately,
if you're going to have a taxation scheme,
you have to tax the people that
have the money, right? You can't,
you can't get blood from
a rock as they say. Right?
So how do you decide
what the level is now?
I get you could live in La and the cost
of living's high and then maybe you'd
say, all right, well I can't, I can't
make it here in a way I wanted to do.
So I want to go somewhere cheap.
But how do you figure out, well,
what is it that is the basic stuff.
I mean,
we're called UBI.
So what is the basic stuff that people
are supposed to have? Well, I mean the,
in terms of the level of the income,
most people are talking about around
a thousand dollars a month. Um,
Finland had a, an experiment where
it was like 600 euros or something.
So these are pretty low
amounts. I mean, you know, try,
can you imagine living on $1,000 a
month? Right? I used to do it. Yeah,
it was not fun.
It's not so easy.
So I think one advantage of these programs
is that they're going to start at a,
at a low level,
and we can imagine that as technology
advances and society becomes more
prosperous,
that that could be raised over time.
But initially it's going
to be a very low level.
So I don't think we have to worry too
much about destroying the incentive for
people to work and so forth.
It's going to give people a very,
very minimal cushion. Um, but they're
still gonna have that incentive to work.
Right.
So interesting because it just does set
all my libertarian bells off that well,
the second you give it to somebody, so
we give 1000 bucks to everybody. Well,
immediately you're going
to have politicians saying
this isn't enough and we
have to make it more and we
have to make it more in that.
Then that becomes the cycle
where [inaudible] is shifting
money around and it's
just because no one's ever gonna no
matter what basic level we get most people
who no one's ever going to be like,
all right,
well they were okay then
that's a real concern. Um,
I would say though that,
you know, a basic income or,
or there are other flavors of
and a guaranteed minimum income,
a negative income tax.
These are ideas that in the past
have been embraced by Libertarians.
Friedrich Hayak was a big proponent
of, of a guaranteed minimum income. Um,
Milton Friedman was for a negative
income tax and the idea is that you're
creating really a market based safety
net, right? Rather than having government,
um, how's people feed people, uh,
control industries or try to take over
businesses and run them in a way that
artificially creates jobs and so forth.
Rather doing that,
just give people some money, let them
go out and participate in the market.
So it actually is a market
oriented libertarian approach
to having some kind of
safety net. But I think you're
the idea of it being politicized.
That's a real concern.
And one,
one thing I actually have suggested in
some of my writing is that we might set
up a separate institution
to kind of manage that.
Maybe something like the Federal Reserve
do it would be independent and not part
of the political process and
might manage the level of,
of a basic income because you
could actually use it also to,
to respond to recessions. For example,
if there's an economic downturn,
maybe pay people a bit more and then
that would help you get out of the
recession. Right? It would be kind
of a Keynesian response to it. Um,
so I think there are a lot
of possibilities there,
but you're right, we don't,
we don't want every politician running
on the platform of I will increase your
basic income, right. That
that wouldn't be good.
So that's something that just strikes me
as sort of real politic related to all
this is just the way people are. Once
you give them something, they want more.
I don't blame people for that.
It's just sort of, exactly.
So that's the way politics works.
So that's something that we need to think
about from the beginning. As I said,
you know, maybe you put it in the
hands of a separate institution.
One other thing I proposed is that maybe
we can build incentives into a basic
income. Um, if people stay in school,
paid them a bit more than people that
just play video games where people go and
work in the community, you know, help
other people pay, pay them a bit more.
So that,
I think it's really important to have
sort of a ladder for people that they feel
they can somehow do better. Because that,
I mean, the issue you raised everywhere,
arrays.
Before that we could create this class
of people that just do nothing is
something to be concerned about.
But there are ideas that we can,
I think employee to,
to really address that.